so good morning everybody welcome to the
launch of the 2019 new drug markets
report thank you all for coming
I just like to introduce our panel today
so it we're very honored to have with us
again today the European Commissioner
Dimitris avramopoulos Commissioner for
migration Home Affairs and citizenship
the Commissioner has launched many
reports with us in the past including
the previous drug markets report and
we're very happy and honored to have him
with us again today we also have on the
panel the MCZ today director Alex emus
Dale and the Europol executive director
madam capping the ball so first of all
the Commissioner will speak so I'd like
to pass the floor to the commissioner
thank you very much thank you thank you
all have a nice day
as it was said before I'm more than
happy to share this event with you today
you know that I'm running the last
minutes here in Brussels
is all supposed to be in Strasbourg
today but he decided to share this
moment with you and the mall are happy
to share this moment with two good
friends and capable directors of their
agencies Katrine and Alexis but out of
that is the high sensitivity of this
issue I had embraced all the efforts
made by the MCD from day one and the
mother had to see that they're very
concrete and tangible results in our
common efforts so again I would like to
express my thanks to you and to your
staff a dream and Alexis and the EU
darts agency for the tremendous bulimic
work you've done during these past years
to address the challenges related to
issues to drug issues
the evidence she provided in the third
European drug market report and the
links to organized crime
it draws on a major contribution to
informing policy makers as well as all
those involved on the ground it's very
important but here together today
because drugs is as much about health as
it is about security if we want to truly
protect our citizens the two must go
hand in hand
legend gentlemen this report presents a
warning picture of Europe's drug market
one that is evolving rapidly drugs are
increasingly potent and pure when they
arrive on the market there has been a
record number of seizures which together
with increased production in the
European Union points to growing
availability of illicit substances we
have also seen the dramatic increase in
new and often highly potent synthetic
substances appearing on the markets
these results in more drug overdoses
deaths and individuals seeking help from
treatment providers and emergency
services but also in more violence and
crime as you know the organized crime
benefits significantly from the drug
trade moreover violence and corruption
launched in in drag producing countries
is now increasingly evident within our
home within the European Union this is
linked in part to the huge profit
that the illicit drugs trade providers
and the growing willingness to use
violent means to extend market share
it is also driven by Europe's growing
importance as a drug producing producing
area organised crime as you're known is
for sorry
organized crime is for good-looking and
quick to innovate in order to reduce
threats to its business model or seize
new opportunities drug markets have
become more digitally enabled when
purchased online they can be rapidly
transported across borders and the
delivered delivered to consumers this
creates new challenges for law
enforcement and this means we must be
equally innovative and forward looking
in our sponsors the drug market is now
one of the major sources of income for
organized crime and is linked to other
areas of criminality or even terrorist
activities it is an important driver for
the recruitment of young people into
criminal organizations and gangs let me
be clear
the increasingly global natural and bits
of groups involved in drug production
and trafficking is a major cross-border
health and security threat confronted
with such a threat the European Union
must step up its efforts to fight these
criminal activities while keeping drugs
policy anchored on a balanced and
evidence-based approach
at the EU level I can say that our
efforts the last five years have started
to bear fruit the latest action plan on
drugs legislation who we adopted new
psychoactive substances provide a
strengthened response to the newly
emerging health and security challenges
in the area of illicit drug use and drug
moreover our work with our international
partners is starting to gain traction
for example durable in cooperation with
euro just and the law enforcement
authorities of Germany the Netherlands
and the United States took down the
second largest market on the dark web
known as The Wall Street market dear
friends I suspect that this will be I
suspect my last press conference as
European Commissioner for migration Home
Affairs and citizenship believe me it
has been a privilege to serve the Union
this last five years and you know you're
know why when I started with you
no one knew one could imagine that
migration security would race to the top
of the European and not only to the
global agenda and stay there and
unfortunately they will be there for
many years
this commission made security priority
from day one we have taken many deciding
decisions to modernize the European
security framework through new
legislation through reinforced
operational cooperation between member
states and through strengthening the
role and involvement of our agencies the
European leaders drug agency and Europe
all as well as all of the agencies in
the justice and Home Affairs family
have played bulimia critical operational
role in our policies without them we
would all have done our jobs less well
over the last five years we have come a
very long way and have accomplished much
but that word is not finished today it
will continue under the new commission
and when it comes to our fight against
drugs
we need to continue showing
determination and commitment in order to
strengthen our fight in all its aspects
for our youth our citizens and of course
our societies once again I'd like to
express my gratitude go to Catherine she
had her name day in Greece yesterday and
to elect to go speaking Greek so I try
to link that book to my country because
I'm going back home and I want to keep
this friendship alive for the future
they've done a fantastic job from
grateful to them Europe is in good hands
commissioners come and go but the
agencies are here and all the words we
have been striving for the last six
years to keep the European project and
the European vision alive and during the
last five years we were confronted with
huge challenges that had put at stake
the European project in the heart that
was migration and security but in all my
efforts I was a combined by capable
people convinced the Europeans that are
here with me today and I wish them all
the best from them for the future thank
you very much for today
thank you very much commissioner I now
like to pass the floor to Alexa Castel
thank you dear commissioner dear
colleagues ladies and gentlemen first I
would like to thank all the staff of emc
DDA and the staff of europe or that
they've been working those three years
collecting the information making all
the analysis of course i have special
thanks to my good and close colleague
cut in the ball the executive director
of europe all for support and for very
close and very fruitful cooperation the
report cover
strengths along the supply chain from
production trafficking to distribution
and sales even if today we are going to
speak more about market than about the
problems associated to the use of those
substances as the commissioner said and
is putting us under challenge because we
launch together the previous report so
what has changed what is new the main
answer is that the European drug market
is changing faster than before both
under the influence of internal and
external drivers and you have in the
report a very detailed and artistic
analysis of those changes what we
observed today is the hyper production
of drugs within and beyond the EU
borders which is leading to high
availability of natural and synthetic
substances this means that now consumers
have access to a diverse range of highly
potent and pure products at a very
affordable price as the Commissioner
mentioned and mounting concern is the
rise in drug-related violence and
corruption within D U and this is a very
worrying evolution of the situation over
the last five years first of all the
drug market remains a major source of
income for organized crime groups in the
UN we estimate that the Europeans are
spending around 30 billions of euros
every year for the retail level it
doesn't encompasses the value of
potential values of seizures of any
interference with the drug business here
we talk only about the money that is
spent by people who are using drugs in
Europe around 2/5 of this total 39% is
spent on cannabis 31% on cocaine that
has taken out the second place not only
as the second most consumed drug but
also in terms of market value and Aaron
is the third with 25 percent finally and
feta means methamphetamines and
MDMA ecstasy represent 5% of that market
let's have a quick look at the key drug
markets put let's then put under the
microscope cannabis is the largest drug
market in Europe worth at least eleven
point six billion of euro with some 25
millions of Europeans who have used
cannabis at least once last year while
cannot be served and raised in state
dominate we see new products that are
appearing on the drug market and this
makes monitoring of the potency and
potential health effects essential we
also observed increased violence that is
associated to the cannabis business
between organized crime groups and this
is putting another strain on law
enforcement activities let's have a look
at error in and order opioids opiates
still account for the largest proportion
of arms associated with drug use and the
error in market is estimate at least at
seven point four billion of euros per
year they are approximately 1.3 million
of people who are considered as problem
of period users mainly of a range
talking about market and trafficking the
Balkan route remains the key corridor
foreign into the EU but there are signs
of increased there in trafficking along
the southern route particularly to
through the Suez Canal there is also
evidence of the dimension of the
chemical precursors that are needed to
produce those drugs and those precursors
they are being produced in Europe and
they are being smuggled and - from the
you - error introduced in Europe we also
noticed as though not in the same
proportion and they need you in the
United States that there are highly
potent synthetic opioids like the
fentanyl derivatives that are
responsible in the u.s. for the big wave
of drug related death while they
represent also in Europe are growing
else risk but still not in the same
proportion these are increasingly traded
online and dispatched by post let's come
now to
drugs that are called a lot of attention
in the recent years which is cocaine
there is a record production and
corresponding expanding markets for for
cocaine with the market retail value
that is estimated minimum 9 point 1
billion of Europe this is the second
most common the most commonly consumed
illicit drugs in the you we have around
4 million of Europeans that reportedly
use the drug in the past year but we
need to add to those people those who
have more recently joined and are
consuming not only cocaine in this more
common version but also crack cocaine
and are worrying signs of an increase in
the use of crack cocaine also in Europe
use is still concentrated insult and
West Europe but the market appears to be
spreading including outside Europe like
for instance in the Western Balkans
record production in Latin America has
intensified trafficking to d u-- mainly
to maritime containers where record
seizures have been recorded and the
presence of european organized crime
groups in latin america is also changing
the dynamic and allowing them to manage
the supply chain and to em it is also
disrupting the market not only in Europe
but in Latin America and there are a lot
of changes intervening in the in the
organization of those trafficking group
between the sources and the EU and also
increasingly it seems that Europe is the
EU is big is emerging as a transit area
for cocaine that is the steam to other
markets like Middle East and Asia for
amphetamine methamphetamine and MDMA the
estimated value is 1.5 billion euro a
year they are produced for domestic
production and export they make a prod
around 5% of the total EU market more
recently we have noticed that the not
only the market is very well controlled
we have also other organized crime
groups that are intervening in the
market for instance Mexican cartels
who are controlling the entire logistic
chain finally the new psychoactive
substances we discovered five and fifty
five new substances one per week on the
European market last year source
countries are China and India the total
of substances that are has been detected
and that are monitored but by the year
MCD DEA together with Europe all and
with the support of other EU agencies
among two 731 substances the NPS
continue to represent a very important
threat to health with potent synthetic
cannabinoids synthetic opioids and fake
benzodiazepines appearing on the market
those create more at the origin of more
health emergencies acute intoxication
and death dear Commissioner dear
colleagues ladies and gentlemen the
contemporary drug market is increasingly
complex adaptive and dynamic it is also
more global in nature and more
interlinked than in the past in addition
as the Commissioner highlighted of the
direct impact on health and security the
drug market has also indirect and
wide-ranging negative consequences on
other important policy areas it includes
violence and Community Safety economic
development and governance and the
environment finally the human and
societal cost associated with the drugs
market remain considerable the reduction
of the harm associated with the drug
market should remain a priority so you
will ask me what can we do on the top of
what was done and the captioner
explained we made some good progress in
the recent five years still we have a
lot of work in front of us the the work
in that area must remain an absolute
priority and this report is a clear we
wake up call for policymakers to address
the rapidly growing drug market our
message is that important progress has
been made but more needs to be done at
the time when a new Commission new
European Commission will take its duties
in the coming days when the EU and the
member states are discussing the
political priorities and actions
for the next European budget 20 2021
2027 we jointly called together with
Europe all for an upgrade of priorities
and resources proportional to the
importance of the emerging threats thank
you very much thank you very much Alexey
I'd now like to give the floor to the
Europe all executive director cap in
Devon thank you
always grateful so you'll have
commissioner dear commissioner dear
Alexis dear colleagues ladies and
gentlemen the availability of drugs in
the EU is at an unprecedented high level
organized crime constitutes the highest
and the most diverse risk for our new
citizens today we present you the draft
report 2019 this is a third edition of
the joint analysis of Europe oh and the
EMC DDA of the illicit drugs market
every three years we publish such a
joint analysis the report is important
because it's the reference for future
strategies to combat drugs production
and drugs trafficking first of all it
focuses on the impact and the
consequences of illicit drugs in the U
and second it looks into the main drugs
markets and it explores also possible
responses on the national level on the
international level to counter the
production of drugs and the service and
the supply of narcotics organized crime
constitutes the highest and the most
diverse risk for the EU Member States
what we see is that the organized crime
groups are becoming more complex highly
international and they infiltrate in the
legal economy poly criminality is a key
feature for them they use more and more
violence and they use more and more
corruption contract killings and other
types of violence associated with drugs
trafficking is increasing and is
expanding in the European Union high
risk crime groups use corruption to
infiltrate
in the public and in the private sector
organizations the drugs market is the
largest criminal market in the European
Union when we look for 2018 to our
intelligence at Europe or level we can
see that the organized crime groups
involved in coca in trafficking - you
may have profited for at least 40
billion euros which is nearly 1/4 of the
2019 you budget same figures from our
intelligence for 2018 for the production
of synthetic drugs in the you by
organized crime groups and we still
believe that these figures are an
underestimation the increasing profits
of organized crime threatens as a
commissioner set and as Alexis set or
internal security or economy the public
health and the integrity asset tracing
has to be reinforced we do not cease
enough and we do not confiscate enough
what can be the report the answers to
concert to counter these threats we need
to support the new member states the
law-enforcement community in the EU
member states in cross-border
investigations even more we need to
support the resource intensive
operations therefore we need to invest
in specialized skills analysis IT
forensic special tactics technical
support we developed with us with the
support of the commissioner the concepts
of the high-value targets and the
operational task forces against
individuals and organizations
constituting the highest security risks
we want to have the big bosses in the
organized crime area we started since
late 2018 with this approach
125 high-value targets were selected 21
operational task forces have been
established 31 investigations have been
supported so far fun 400 suspects were
arrested including 51 high-value targets
and the seizure of a variety of essence
targeted investigation proved to have a
broad security impact beyond specific
right areas and to increase the impact
against trucks trafficking and organized
crime we believe that we need to
intensify the exchange of operational
information even more we have to
increase our focus and our presence at
the geographical locations we need
cooperation outside that you with the
source countries we need a common you
response to criminal use of the new
technology and here innovative
approaches or key encrypted
communications online Tait trade
cryptocurrencies are current now in the
use by series and organized crime groups
more investments in Europol and more
investments in the EMC DDA to support
all these measures are needed the
European Union and especially the
Commissioner for justice and Home
Affairs you have been done you have done
a lot in the past and we hope that we
can continue and even strengthen the
approach regarding serious and organised
crime in the European Union with a focus
on drugs thank you very much thank you
very much so before we move to the Q&A
session where you'll be able to ask your
technical questions to both agencies
that the Commissioner will have to leave
us for another appointment but if you'd
like to say your goodbyes now and take a
picture well I said what I had to say
before living in two days
actually my last institution and
activity in madrasas once again I'd like
to thank you all to make the green and
Alexis as opposed to the people behind
them who who are doing the very job we
shall keep being implanted we don't know
what the future is called for us but one
thing is sure what we have done in the
last four years can establish the very
strong and good friendship and
relationship I will show the best Thanks
[Music]